right now in in america lots of other
places i mean this is true for most of
europe that's true from most democratic
countries
the kids they're the kids the adults
people's brains are snapped shut like a
trap somebody starts talking about bible
and and they they think oh that's that
primitive dark ages stuff that you know
that
that we got rid of people people are
scared of it people are are you know
they just think it's like you you must
be some kind of idiot for talking about
this stuff
and as long as
the
the the bible continues to be under this
uh shadow instead of being
this spectacular document that created
the world we live in
instead of that people just keep saying
oh that's the dark ages
i get you on the on the liberal part i
say you know i talk about bill maher all
the time where the five remaining sane
liberals in america they just are sort
of in this slow motion paralysis and two
years later they get it they repeat what
a bunch of us say but they keep voting
for the wrong people so i'm with you on
that but what would you say is it is not
enough
uh for say what ron desantis is doing in
florida i mean i can tell you from
living here for four months i'm living
in a a free state that feels strong and
defended and uh it is starkly different
than california which made all of the
wrong decisions and went that route
well i i think the number one thing
is that um
sending kids to schools
where uh five days a week or or whatever
it is they
they spend their time in an environment
that is
um stripped of any reference to
god or to the bible as the basis of of
western
civilization the bible is the the the
fundamental text on on which
western tradition was built i i i think
that that doesn't work because
and i
i try to go into the
uh into the psychology of all of this
and and you know how how it actually
works because i think people don't don't
understand this
if if you want anything
right you know
young people are always saying what do
you mean conservative conservatives
don't conserve anything right you've
heard that i mean people say that all
the time is like like what have
conservatives succeeded in conserving in
the you know in the last 50 years and i
think we have to take that argument
seriously that
there's a constant rolling cultural
revolution and the reason for the
constant rolling cultural revolution
which just rips up one thing after
another is because of the fact nobody
nobody's focused on how how do how does
the transmission
the conservation of ideas actually work
and for it the way it actually works
is that
if you're a kid
and you see that people give that the
people around you give honor to
something like
let's say the bible they they give honor
to it what do you mean they say look
this is really important now i'm not
talking about you know
them saying you have to believe this or
if you don't believe this then you're a
terrible person or i'm talking something
much more basic
that if you're an environment where
people are giving honor they say look
this constitution is you know the the
the best that you know that that there's
been in the world and this scripture
is the the best moral framework for
leading your life that there's ever been
when you hear that from
people you respect your mind opens up
right everybody's always saying oh your
mind closes i that's not my experience
if people are saying look this is just
really important you should take a look
at it
your mind opens up to learning
and right now in in america lots of
other places i mean this is true for
most of europe that's true for most
democratic countries
the kids they're the kids the adults
people's brains are
snapped shut like a trap somebody starts
talking about bible and and they they
think oh that's that primitive dark ages
stuff that you know that
that we got rid of people people are
scared of it people are are
you know
they just think it's like you you must
be some kind of idiot for talking about
this stuff and as long as
the
the the bible continues to be under this
uh shadow instead of being
uh this spectacular document that
created the world we live in instead of
that people just keep saying oh that's
the dark ages
so the the the disintegration of what
used to be america
uh
like it it's inevitable you you you
pulled all of the you know the vacuum
tubes out of the back of the television
i mean that's like i'm dating myself you
put you pulled all the tran you sorry
about the hdmi wire yeah right you
pulled right you pulled right you pulled
all the tr the the the the the red and
the yellow
yeah you know the
the little square things in the back you
pulled them out and you stepped on them
you get what i'm saying so and then
you're surprised the thing stops working
so you got to get it working again and
to get it working again we need to be
able to give honor to those things that
allowed our ancestors to to create a
free and constrained and decent society
so i hate to keep bringing this back to
florida but you know that it's really
just on my mind these days and i'm so
impressed with what's going on here so i
think i sense what you're saying is
basically florida is doing a pretty darn
good job you'd like to see the
reinstitution of some religious teaching
in school you do make a carve out
for let's say the the non-believers or
people of minority religions etc etc
but but is that it is i mean is that
basically the only thing that you think
is going wrong because to me what's
happening here right now at a secular
level and and i don't even think it's
purely at a secular level desantis
doesn't talk about religion a lot as far
as i know but he's talking about reality
and i think his reality is based in
something
yeah i i i i'm look i i don't want to
look i i like desantis and i like what
he's doing
but i i think that what's what what's
sort of missing from the conversation is
is a
is a longer view
that that's what i mean because because
because everything that's going on
right now is is mostly reactive
it's reacting against the excesses of uh
of of of
woke neo marxism and god bless him for
doing that and and the legislature and
you know and chris ruffo and all the
people who are working at the grassroots
level god bless them and they they
really are trying to save their country
and and i hope they succeed
but
you know we're at the very very
beginning of this
and what's actually going to happen is
uh as
um
as christian activists like
like ruffo start to you know get
just look beyond
um just reacting and trying to like like
like
try to get the worst of the stuff out of
the schools
you're gonna find out that
that's not enough to transmit anything
it it it's just not i mean the the
schools without the woke stuff
from 15 years ago that's how we got here
right in other words
the way that we got to the mess that
we're in now is that 15 and 20 years ago
everything was run by liberals
and and so i'm i'm just trying to look
just a little bit beyond the horizon and
i i no i don't i don't think it's just a
matter of
of education but i i don't want to speak
for i look i i i think there's going to
be a number of different different
states and countries and they're going
to try different things
so
some of those things could be um you
know uh
the the the the they could be sabbath
laws you know some people might want to
try
might want to try having sabbath laws
they could be
um uh
uh
legislation about what the family is
there could be legislation about
abortion i mean it could be all sorts of
things
and i think a smart governor
or or or leader
what what he would do is he would say
look i i don't want to take the most
controversial stuff and like try to
force it on people that i mean that
that's just not smart leadership i i
think that in every state what will
happen is uh conservative leadership
will
will say
what are the kinds of things that you
know that we have a majority and they
can get behind this and and they they
think that this could make sense
and they'll try different things and and
they'll they'll you know they'll see
what what can work and they'll do
experiments if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell